hey morning everyone welcome back so
last week you heard about logistic
regression and generalized linear models
and it turns out all of the learning
algorithms we were learning about so far
are called discriminative learning
algorithms which is one big bucket of
learning algorithms and today what I'd
like to do is share of you how
generative learning algorithms work in
particular you learn about Gaussian
disparate analysis so by the end of the
day you know how to implement this and
it turns out that compared to say
logistic regression for classification
GDA is actually a simpler and maybe more
computationally efficient algorithm to
implement in some cases so and it
sometimes works better if you have very
small data sets sometimes with some
caveats and it was helpful comparison
between generative learning algorithms
which is the new class of albums you
hear about today versus the spirit of
learning algorithms and then we'll talk
about naive Bayes and how you can use
that to build a spam filter for example
so um we'll use finally classification
as the motivating example for today and
if you have a data set that looks like
this with two crosses then what a
discriminative learning algorithm like
logistic regression would do is use
gradient descent to search for a line
that separates the positive negative
examples right save you Rand additional
randomly initialize parameters may be
thoughts of some digit about me like
that and over the course of gradient
descent you know the line my grades or
evolves until you get maybe a line like
that there separates the positive and
negative examples and the diss
aggression is really searching for a
line searching for decision boundary
that separates the positive and negative
examples and so if this was the
malignant tumors and the benign tumors
example right that's that's what they
just seek regression with you now
there's a different class of algorithm
which isn't searching for this separate
we doesn't try to maximize the
likelihood that you the way you saw last
week which is here's an alternative just
called a generative learning algorithm
which is rather than looking the two
classes and trying to find a separation
instead the algorithm is going to look
at the closest one at a time first will
look at all of the malignant tumors
right in the cancer example and try to
build a model for what malignant tumors
looks like so you might say Oh looks
like all the malignant tumors roughly
all the malignant tumors roughly live in
that ellipse and then you look at all
the benign tumors in isolation and say
oh looks like all the benign tumors
roughly live in that ellipse and then a
classification time if there's a new you
know patient in your office with those
features it would then look at this new
patient and compare it to the malignant
tumor model compared to the benign tumor
model and then say in this case it looks
like this one looks a lot more like the
benign tumors I had previously seen so
I'm going to classify that as a benign
tumor so rather than looking at both
houses simultaneously and searching for
a way to separate them a generative
learning algorithm instead builds a
model of what each of the classes looks
like kind of almost in isolation what
some details we'll learn about later and
then that test time and evaluates a new
example against the benign model eval
this against the malignant model and
tries to see which of the two models it
matches more closely against so let's
formalizes on a discriminative learning
algorithm learns P of Y give
X right well it learns right some
mapping from X to Y directly learn or I
can learn I think on and briefly talked
about the perceptron algorithm it's
helpful support vector machines later we
learn it's a function mapping from X to
the labels directly so that's a
discriminative learning algorithm or
you're trying to discriminate between
positive and negative classes in
contrast a generative learning algorithm
it learns P of X given Y so this says
what are the features like given the
cost right so instead of P of Y given X
we're gonna learn P of X given Y so in
other words given that the tumor is
malignant what are the features likely
gonna be like or given the tumors benign
what are the features X gonna be like
okay and then as and then they'll also
generative learning algorithm will also
learn P of Y so this is a this is also
called the class prior this probability
yes right it's called the cost price
just when the patient walks into your
office before you've even examined them
before even seen them what are the odds
that their tumor is malignant versus
benign right before you see anything
just okay and so using Bayes rule if you
can build a model for P of x given Y and
for P of Y if you know if you can
calculate numbers for both of these
quantities then using Bayes rule when
you have a new test example with
features X you can then calculate the
chance of Y being equal to one
this right where P of X and so if you
learned this term if you have X given Y
then you can plug that in here
and if you've also learned this term P
of Y you can plug that in here
so P of X in the denominator okay so if
you learned both both of those terms in
the red square and the RS square you
could plug it into all of those terms
and therefore use Bayes rule to
calculate P of y equals 1 given X so
give it a new patient with features X
you could use this formula calculate
what's the chance that the tumor is
malignant
if you've estimated you know these these
two quantities in the red and nd orange
circles okay so um that's the framework
were used to build generative learning
algorithms and in fact today you see two
examples of generative learning
algorithms one for continuous value
features we should use for things like
the tumor classification and one for
discrete features which you can use for
building like an email spam filter right
oh I don't know if you want to download
to their things and see how positive and
negative the sentiment on Twitter is or
something right you so have a natural
language processing example later so um
let's talk about Gaussian distributed
the house
so let's develop this model assuming
that the features X are continuous
values and when we develop generative
learning algorithms I'm going to use X
in RN so you know I'm going to drop the
X 0 equals 1 convention so I'm not gonna
we're not gonna need that extra make
Zuko's 1 so X is now RN rather than RN
plus 1 and the key assumption in
Gaussian test grant analysis is we're
going to assume that P of X given Y it's
distributed Gaussian right in other
words condition on the tumors being
malignant the distribution of the
features is Gaussian you know the
features like size of the size of the
tumor the the cell adhesion whatever
features you use to measure a tumor and
condition on it being benign the
distribution is also Gaussian so um
watching how many of you are familiar
with a multivariate Gaussian raise your
hand if you are like half of you
one-third know two-fifths okay cool
all right oh how many of you are
familiar of a univariate like a single
dimensional Gaussian okay cool almost
everyone all right cool
so let me let me just go through what is
a multivariate Gaussian distribution
so the Gaussian is this familiar
bell-shaped curve a multivariate
Gaussian is a generalization of this
familiar bell-shaped curve over one
dimensional random variable to multiple
random variables at the same time vector
value random variables browsing
random variable so um Z the security
Gaussian with some mean vector mu and
some covariance matrix Sigma so if Z is
in RN then mu would be our end as well
and Sigma the covariance matrix would be
n by n so these two dimensional use two
dimensional Sigma's two dimensional and
you expected value of Z is equal to the
mean and the covariance of Z if you're
familiar with multivariate coherencies
this is the formula right and this
simplifies that we showed the lecture
now so you get this R election O's sorry
and following sometimes semi standard
convention sometimes gonna admit the
square brackets so instead of writing
the expected value of Z meaning the mean
of Z sometimes I just write to this easy
right Omega omit the square brackets to
simplify the notation a bit okay and the
derivation from this step to this step
is given the lecture notes and so the
priority density function for a Gaussian
looks like this and this is one that
those formulas dead oh no when you're
implementing these algorithms you use it
over and over but what I've seen for a
lot of people is almost no one well very
few people stop their machine learning
memorize this formula just look at every
time you need it I'm using so many times
I seem to have it steered in my brain by
now but most people don't but when you
just sitting a few you you end up
memorizing it but let me show you some
pictures of what this looks like since I
think that would that might be more
useful
so the multi grousing density has two
parameters mu and Sigma they control the
mean and the variance of this density
okay
so this is a picture of the Gaussian
density this is a two dimensional
Gaussian bump and for now I've set the
mean parameter to zero so mu is the two
dimensional parameter zero zero which is
why this Gaussian bump is centered at
zero and the covariance matrix Sigma is
the identity is the identity matrix so
so you know so so you have this standard
this is also called the standard
Gaussian distribution which means to
mean zero and covariance equals to the
identity now I'm gonna take the
covariance matrix and shrink it right so
take a covariance matrix and multiply it
by a number less than 1 that should
shrink the variance reduce the
variability and distributions but I do
that the density the probably density
function becomes taller this is a
probably density function so it always
integrates to 1 right the area under the
curve
you know it's 1 and so by reducing the
covariance from the identity to 0.6
times the identity it reduces the spread
of the Gaussian density but it also
makes it tall as a result because you
know the area under the curve must
integrate to 1 now let's make it fatter
let's make the covariance two times the
identity that you end up with a wider
distribution where the values of I guess
the axes here this would be the Z 1 and
Z 2 axis the two dimensions of the
Gaussian density right increases the
variance of the density so let's go back
to a standard Gaussian covariance equal
1 1 now let's try filling around with
the off diagonal entries I'm good so
right now the off diagonal entries are 0
right so in this Gaussian density the
off diagonal elements are 0 0
let's increase that to 0.5 and see what
happens so you do that then the Gaussian
density who can see the change it goes
from this round shape to this slightly
narrower thing let's increase the
further to point eight point eight then
the density ends up looking like that
where now it's more likely that Z 1 now
Z 1 and Z 2 are positively correlated
okay so let's go through all of these
parts but now looking at contours of
these Gaussian densities and Southeast
VD bumps so this is the contours of the
Gaussian density when the covariance
matrix is the identity matrix and
pologize the aspect ratio these are
supposed to be perfectly round circles
but the aspect ratio makes us look a
little bit that's it but this is
supposed to be perfectly round circles
and so when the covariance matrix is the
identity matrix
you know Z 1 and Z 2 are uncorrelated
and contours of the Gaussian bump of the
Gaussian density look like round circles
and if you're increasing off diagonal
excuse me then it looks like that
increase it further two point eight
point eight it looks like that okay
we're now most of the property mass part
most probably density function places
value on z1 and z2 being positively
correlated next let's look at what
happens if we set off diagonal elements
to negative values right so actually
what do you think will happen let's set
the off diagonals to negative point five
point five well people seem to only
think that hand gesture okay cool
right right so do you and download the
two random variables and negative
correlation so you end up with from this
type of probably density function right
and in contours it looks like this okay
whereas now slanted the other way so now
z1 is easy to have the negative
correlation
and that's plenty of way okay all right
so so far we've been keeping the mean
vector as zero and just fearing the
covariance matrix oh good yeah yes every
covariance matrix is symmetric
everything of the covariance matrix is
interesting column vectors that point
interesting directions not really
let me think maybe she's not I I think
the covariance matrix is always
symmetric and so I would usually not
look at single columns of the covariance
matrix in isolation we talked about
principal components analysis talk about
the eigen vectors of the covariance
matrix which are the principal
directions in which it points that yeah
I'll get to that oh yes so the eigen
vectors the covariance matrix points in
the principal axes of units that's
defined by the contours yeah okay um so
there's a standard Gaussian with mean
zero so the Gaussian bump is centered at
zero zero because mu is zero zero let's
move move around so I'm going to move
you know mu 2 0 1 point 0 1 point 5 so
that moves the Gaussian the position of
Gaussian density right now let's move it
different location move it
minus 1 point 5 minus 1 and so by
varying the value of mu you could also
shift the center of the Gaussian density
around okay
so I hope this gives you a sense of as
you vary the parameters the mean and the
covariance matrix of the 2d Gaussian
density the source are probably very
density functions you can get as a
result of changing mu and Sigma okay
yeah the questions about this
[Music]
so
here's the GTA right model and let's see
so remember if I G da we need to model P
of x given Y right is that P of Y given
X so I'm going to write this separately
in two separate equations here x given y
equals zero so what's the chance
what's the priority density of the
features if is a benign tumor I'm gonna
see them as Gaussian so I write out the
formula for Gaussian
and then similarly I'm going to assume
that if is a malignant tumors of Y is
equal to one that the density of the
features is also Gaussian and one point
out a couple things so the parameters of
the GDA model are mu 0 mu 1 and Sigma
and for reasons we're going to a little
bit we use the same Sigma for both
classes but we'll use different means 0
and 1 okay and we can come back to this
later if you want you could use separate
parameters you know Sigma 0 and Sigma 1
but that's not usually done so we're
gonna assume that the two gaussians for
the positive and negative classes have
the same covariance matrix but they have
different means you don't have to make
this assumption but this is the way it's
most commonly done and you can talk
about the reason why we tend to do that
in a second so this is a model for P of
Y given X the other thing we need to do
is model P of Y so Y is just a Bernoulli
random variable right it takes on you
know the value 0 or 1 and so I'm going
to write it like this Phi to the Y times
1 minus Phi to the 1 minus and you saw
this kind of notation when we talked
about logistic regression but all this
means is that you know probably of Y
being equal to 1 is equal to Phi right
because Y is either 0 1 and so this is a
way of writing
part of why equals 1 is equal to 5 and
you saw a similar exponentiation
notation when we're talking about
logistic regression right one week ago
last Monday and so the last parameter
that is fine so this is our n this is
also our n but this is far and by n and
that's just a real number which is zero
and one
so for any lessee so if you can fit
museum you one Sigma and fighter your
data then these parameters will define P
of X given Y and P of Y and so if at
test time you have a new patient walked
into your office and you need to compute
this then you can compute write these
things in the red and the orange boxes
each of these is a number and by
plugging all these numbers in the
formula you get a number alpha P y
equals 1 given X and you can then
predict you know malignant or benign
tumor so let's talk about how to fit the
parameters so you have a training set as
usual I'm gonna write the training let
me write the training set like this x iy
I for I equals 1 through m this is a
usual training set and what we're going
to do in all the fifties parameters is
maximize the joint likelihood and in
particular let me define the likelihood
of the parameters to be equal to the
product from I equals 1 through m
compute X my Y I you know parameterize
by
and I'm just like drop the parameters
here okay and the big difference between
a generative learning algorithm like
this compared to a discriminative
learning algorithm is that the cost
function you maximize is this joint
likelihood which is P of X comma Y
whereas for a discriminative learning
algorithm we were maximizing this other
thing which is sometimes also called the
conditional likelihood so the big
difference between the these two cost
functions is that for logistic
regression or linear rational
generalizes any models you are trying to
choose from this data they maximize P of
Y given X but for generative learning
algorithms we're going to try to choose
parameters to maximize P of X and y or P
of X comma Y right so
so if you use them that's more like good
estimation so you choose the parameters
Phi nu 0 nu 1 and Sigma they maximize
the log likelihood right where this
define as you know log likelihood that
we define out there and so we actually
ask you to do this as a problem set in
the next homework but so the way you
maximize this is look at that formula
for the likelihood take logs take
derivatives of this thing set to there's
equal to 0 and then solve for the values
of the parameters and maximize this
whole thing and I'll just tell you the
answers you're supposed to get but then
you start to do the derivation right the
value of Phi that maximizes this is you
know not that surprisingly so so Phi is
the estimate of probably of Y being
equal to 1 right so what's the chance
when the next patient walks into your
doctor's office that they have a
malignant tumor and so the maximum I
could spend 4 5 is it's just of all of
your training examples what's the
fraction with labor y equals 1 right so
it's the maximum I could have the bias
of a coin toss is just well count of the
fraction of hands you got okay so this
is it
and one other way to write this is sum
from I equals 1 through m indicator
right um let's see so software indicates
a notation on Wednesday did you stop
what indicated notation or is it okay oh
so this notation is an indicator
function we're indicator why I equals
one is return zero one depend on whether
the thing inside is true right so
there's an indicator notation in which
our indicator of a true statement is
equal to one an indicator of a false
statement is equal to zero so that's
another way of writing writing this
formula and then the maximum likelihood
estimate form u 0 is this I'll just
write out and so well actually if you
put aside the math for now what do you
think it's a master like an estimated at
the mean of all of the features for the
benign tumors right well what you do is
you take all the benign tumors and your
training set and just take their average
that seems like a very reasonable way
just look look at your training set look
at all of the ailment
look at all of the benign tumors all the
olds are yes and then just take the mean
of these and that you know seems like a
pretty reasonable way to estimate mu
zero look at all the negative examples
and average their features so this is a
way of writing out that intuition so the
denominator is sum from I equals 1
through m indicator why I equals zero
and so the denominator will count up the
number of examples that have benign
tumors right because every time why I
equals zero you get an extra one in this
sum and so the denominator ends up be
the total number of benign tumors in
your training set okay
and the numerator some particles won't
be an indicator is a benign tumor times
X I so the effect of that is whenever a
tumor is benign is one times the
features whenever an example is
malignant is 0 times the features and so
the numerator is summing up all the
features all the feature vectors for all
of the examples that are benign I just
write this out so this is some feature
vectors for for all the examples y
equals 0 the denominators number of
examples y equals 0 ok and then if you
take this ratio if you take this
fraction then you're summing up all that
the feature vectors for the benign
tumors divided by the total number of
benign tumors in the training set and so
that's just a mean of the feature
vectors of all of the benign examples
right much more likely for new one no
surprise this is kind of what you'd
expect some of all of the positive
examples and divided by the total number
of positive examples and get their mean
so that's that's my favorite for new one
and then I just write this out if you're
familiar with covariance matrices this
formula may not surprise you but if
you're less familiar
then I guess you can see the details in
the homework don't worry too much about
that
oh you can unpack the details in the
legend also wonderful works but the
covariance matrix they see try sir you
know fit two contours to them like we
saw so so Charlie for the Gaussian to
both of these with these corresponding
means but you want one covariance matrix
to both of these okay so these are the
so the way so the way I motivated this
was you know I said well if you want to
estimate the mean of a coin toss
discounted fraction coin tosses they
came up heads and then it seems that the
mean for Museum new one you just look at
these examples and pick the mean right
so that was the intuitive explanation to
how you get these formulas but the
mathematics ound way to get these
formulas is not by this intuitive
argument that I just gave is instead to
look at the likelihood take loss give
the log-likelihood take the return
sentence is equal to zero solve for all
these values and prove more formally
that these are the actual values that
maximize this thing right by by saying
there's is your in solving so you can
see that for yourself in the problem
sets okay so
finally having to fit these parameters
if you want to make a prediction right
so give it a new patience
how do you make a prediction for whether
they are tumor is malignant or benign so
if you want to predict the most likely
cross label you choose max over Y a P of
Y given X and by Bayes rule this is max
over Y appear x given Y P of Y divided
by P of X okay now I want to introduce
one issue well one more piece of
notation which is should use thank you
how many of you are familiar with the R
max notation most of you okay cool I'll
go over this quickly so um an example
sodium let's see so you know the min
over Z of Z minus 5 squared is equal to
0 because the smallest possible value of
Z by 5 squared 0 and the Augmon over Z
of Z minus 5 squared is equal to 5 ok so
the min is the smallest possible value
attained by the thing inside and the
argument is the value you need to plug
in to achieve that smallest possible
value so the prediction you actually
want to make if you want to output a
value for y you don't want output a
probability right you don't say well
what do I think is value of y so you
might choose a value of y then maximize
so there's the OGG max of this and this
would be either zero or one right so
that's equal to our class of that and
you notice that this denominator is just
a constant right it doesn't doesn't it's
a P of X is why does even appear in
there it's just some positive number and
so this is equal to just off max over Y
P of X given Y times y so when
implementing when when making
predictions we've gas industry and now
with a generative learning algorithm
sometimes to save on computation you
don't bother to calculate the
denominator if all you care about this
to make a prediction but if you actually
need that probability then you have to
normalize the problem wasn't okay so
let's examine what DRM is doing
all right so let's look at the same data
set and compare and contrast what a
discriminative loading algorithm versus
a generative learning algorithm will do
on this data set here's an example with
two features x1 x2 and positive negative
examples so let's start with destructive
learning algorithm let's say you
initialize the parameters randomly
typically when you run which is a
Russian I almost always initialize
Frances is 0 but that is just you know
more interesting to start off for the
personal visualization a random line I
guess and then if you run one iteration
of gradient descent on the conditional
likelihood one iteration of which is
Russian moves the line there there's two
iterations three iterations for
durations and so on and after about 20
iterations that converge to that pretty
decent distributive boundary so that's
logistic regression really searching for
a line to separate positive and negative
examples how about the generative
learning algorithm what it does is the
following which is fit with gas industry
analysis what would do is fit gaussians
to the positive and negative examples
right and then just one one one
technical detail I describe this as if
we look at the two classes separately
because we use the same covariance
matrix Sigma for the positive and
negative classes we actually don't quite
look at them totally separately but we
do fit two gals in densities to the
positive is negative examples and then
what we do is for each point try to
decide what is this class label using
Bayes rule using that formula and it
turns out that this implies the
following decision boundary right so
points to the upper right of this
decision boundary that straight line I
just drew you are closer to the negative
class you end up classifying them as
negative examples and points to the
lower left of that line you enter
classifiers for you as positive examples
and I've also drawn in green here the
decision boundary for logistic
so so so these two algorithms actually
come up with slightly different decision
boundaries okay but the way you arrive
at these two-digit about these are a
little bit different so any questions
about this yeah
[Music]
oh sure yes good questions so um why do
we use two separate means museum you one
and single covariance matrix Sigma it
turns out that well it turns out that if
you choose to build the model this way
the decision boundary ends up being
linear and so for a lot of problems and
wanted then it is your boundary yeah and
it turns out you could choose to use two
separate covariance matrix Sigma 0 and
Sigma 1 and don't actually work ok right
this is actually very visible to do so
as well
but you double the number of parameters
roughly and you end up with decision
boundary that isn't linear anymore but
it's actually not as I reason allowed to
do that as well
no this one
now there's one very interesting
property about Gaussian discriminant
analysis and it turns out that's well
let's let's compare gtatyr logistic
regression
and for a fixed set of parameters right
so let's say you learn some set of
parameters I'm going to do any exercise
where we're going to plot P of y equals
1 given X you know parametrize by all
these things right as a function of X so
I'm gonna do this no exercise in a
second but what this means is um well
this formula this is equal to P of x
given y equals 1 you know which is
parametrized by write the various
parameters a times P of y equals 1
franchise by PI divided by P of X which
depends on all the parameters I guess
so by Bayes rule you know this formula
is equal to this little thing and just
as we saw earlier I guess right once you
have fixed all the parameters that's
just a number you compute by evaluating
the Gaussian density this is a Bernoulli
probability so actually P of y equals 1
parametrized by 5 is just equal to 5 is
that second term and you similarly
calculate the denominator and so for
every value of x you can compute this
ratio and thus get a number for the
chance of wiping on the 1 given X so we
go through one example of what function
you get for P of y equals 1 given X for
what function you get for this if you
actually plot this for different values
of X so um let's see let's see you have
just one feature X so X is a and let's
say that you have a few negative
examples there and a few positive
examples there right so simple dataset
okay
and let's see what gas industry analysis
will do on this day the same with just
one feature so that's why all the data
is possible 1d so let me map all this
data to x-axis I just have to say that
mapped it down and if you fit a Gaussian
to each of these two data sets then you
end up with you know Gaussian just
follows where this bump on the left is P
of x given y equals 0 and this bump on
the right is P of x given y equals 1
right and again this is technical detail
that we
at the same variance to the two
gaussians but you know you kind of model
the Gaussian densities of well this
cause zero look like what is possible in
the white were two Gaussian bumps like
this oh and then because the dataset is
50/50 you know P of y equals 1 is 0.5
right so one half prior okay now let's
go through that exercise I just drive on
the left of trying to plot P of y equals
1 given X for different values of X so
the vertical axis here is P of y equals
1 given different values of X so um
let's pick a point far to the left here
right with this model you if you
actually calculate this ratio you find
that every other point here it almost
certainly came from this Gaussian on the
left right if only example here you're
almost 30 came from the cause zero
Gaussian because the chance of this
Gaussian generating example all the way
to the left is almost zero right and so
chance of P P of y equals 1 given X is
very small so for a point like that you
end up with a point you know very close
to zero let's pick another point all
right how about this point the midpoint
well if you get an example rather than
the midpoint here you really have no
idea you in can tell did this come from
the negative or the positive Gaussian
kanto right so this is really 5050 so I
guess if this is a 0.5 for that midpoint
you would have PF y equals 1 given X is
0.5 and then if you go to point way to
the right if you're an example way here
then you'll be pretty sure this came
from the positive examples and so you
know you get a point like that right now
it turns out that if you repeat this
exercise sweeping from left to right for
many many points on the x axis you find
that for points far to the left the
chance of this coming from the y equals
1 cost is very small and as you approach
this midpoint it increases to 0.5 and it
surpasses 0.5
and then beyond a certain point it
becomes very very close to one right and
we do this exercise and actually just
for every point you know for a dense
period on the x-axis evaluate this
formula which will give you a number
between zero and one this is probability
here and go ahead and plot you know the
values you get a curve like this and it
turns out that if you connect up the
dots then this is exactly a sigmoid
function the shape of that turns out to
be exactly a shade sigmoid function and
you prove this in two problem sets as
well so both logistic regression and
Gaussian discriminatees actually end up
using a sigmoid function to calculate
you know P of y equals 1 given X well
the outcome ends up being a sigmoid
function I guess the mechanics is you
actually use this calculation rather
than computer signal but um the specific
choice of the parameters they end up
choosing are quite different and you saw
when I was projecting the results on the
display just now in PowerPoint that the
two algorithms actually come up with two
different decision boundaries so um
let's discuss when a generative
algorithm like GTA is superior and when
a destructive algorithm like logistic
regression is superior
all right so GD a Gaussian to spend
analysis so the generative approach this
assumes that x given y equals 0 this is
Gaussian with mean mu 0 and covariance
Sigma this humours x given y equals 1
this is Gaussian with mean mu1 the cover
in Sigma and y is Bernoulli CounterSpy
and what logistic regression does this
is a dispersive algorithm with some
strange win at the back is it listen
okay cool all right
yeah boy no there's just the scary UN
report on global warming over the
weekend I hope we don't already have
Sloane's here ok did you guys see the UN
report on is slightly scary actually it
was a year of falling global warming but
hopefully all right good hurricanes
stopped let's see
so what logistic regression assumes is P
of y equals 1 given X you know that this
is governed by logistic function right
so just me know 1 over 1 plus e to the
negative theta transpose X where some
details about x0 equals 1 so just just
okay so in other words uh is assumed
that this is um pure Michaels wanna keep
an axis logistic okay
and the argument did I just described
just now plotting you know P of y equals
1 given X point by point they're really
the sigmoid curve I drew on the other
board what that illustrates it doesn't
prove it you prove yourself in the
homework problem but what that
illustrates is that this set of
assumptions implies that P of y equals 1
given X is governed by logistic function
but it turns out that the implication in
the opposite direction is not true so if
you assume P of y equals 1 given X is
governed by logistic function by by the
shape this does not in any way shape or
form assume that X given Y is Gaussian X
cubed y equal 0 Skousen using 1 1 is
Gaussian so what this means is that G da
the generative learning a verb in this
case this makes a stronger set of
assumptions and which is aggression
makes a weaker set of assumptions
because you could prove these
assumptions from these assumptions and
by the way as as a lessee and so what
you see in a lot of learning algorithms
is that if you mix strongly modeling
assumptions and if your modeling
assumptions are roughly correct then
your model will do better because you're
telling more information to the
algorithm so if indeed X given Y is
Gaussian then G da will do better
because you're telling the algorithm X
given Y is Gaussian and
can be more efficient and so even if you
have a very small data set if these
assumptions are roughly correct then GA
will do better and the problem with GDA
is if these assumptions turn out to be
wrong
so if X given Y is not at all Gaussian
then this might be very bad set of
assumptions to make you might be trying
to fit a Gaussian density the data that
is not at all Gaussian and then G here
would do more poorly ok so here's one
fun fact here's another example get to
your question second which is um let's
say the following are true let's say
that x given y equals 1 is a song with
parameter lambda 1 and x given y equals
0 this possum with a mean lambda 0
another one non 0 and y as before is
Bernoulli right it turns out that this
set of assumptions also imply that P of
y equals 1 given X its logistic ok and
you could prove this and this is
actually true for any generalized linear
model actually where where where the
difference between these students
distributions varies only according to
the natural parameter as a generalized
name excuse me a special family
distribution and so what this means is
that if you don't know if your data is
Gaussian or possum
if you're using logistic regression you
don't need to worry about it we're fine
either way all right so so you know
maybe your fitting data this may be
fitting a model binary classification
model to some data and you don't know is
the data Gaussian is it possum is this
some other exponential county model
maybe you still know but to be fitting
which is a Russian it'll do fine under
all of those scenarios but if your data
was actually possum but you assumed it
was Gaussian then your model might do
quite poorly ok so the key high-level
principles when you take away from this
if you make weaker assumptions as in
logistic regression then your algorithm
will be more robust to modeling
assumptions such as accidentally
assuming the data is Gaussian it is not
but on the flip side if you have a very
small data set then using a model that
makes more assumptions will actually
allow you to do better because by making
more assumptions you're just telling the
algorithm more truth about the world
which is you know hey algorithm the
world is Gaussian and if it is Gaussian
then it will actually do to do better
oh yeah press the sample what's out day
there is a chasm property you know is
yeah you know it's a matter of degree
right most data on this universe is
Gaussian except for the speed data I
guess yeah but I think is that here a
matter of degree right if you plot
actually you take continuous value data
no there are there exceptions you can
plot it and most data that you plot you
know will not really be Gaussian but a
lot of it you can convince yourself is
very calcium so I think of all those in
how to degree actually tell you the way
I choose to use them these two
algorithms so I think that the whole
world has moved toward using bigger into
a data sense very digital society which
is a lot of data and so for a lot of
problems we have a llama theater I would
probably use logistic regression because
with more data you can overcome telling
the algorithm less about the world right
so so the algorithm has two sources of
knowledge one source of knowledge is
what did you tell it what the
assumptions you told it to make and the
second source of knowledge is learned
from the data and in this ever big data
we have a lot of data you know there is
a strong trend to use logistic
regression which makes less assumptions
and just lets the other and figure out
whether it wants to figure out from the
data right now
one practical reason why I still use
algorithms like that GDA Jones Experian
Alice's well algorithms like this
is that is actually quite competition
efficient and so there's actually one
use case that landing they are then
working on where we just need to fit a
ton of models and don't have the
patience to run logistic regression over
and over and it turns out computing
meaning variances of covariance matrices
is very efficient and so there's
actually apart from the assumptions type
of benefit which is a general
philosophical point we'll see again
later in this course right this idea
about do you make strong or weak
assumptions this is a general principle
in machine learning that we'll see a
game in other places but at the very
concrete the other reason I tend to use
GDA these days is less than I think
could perform better from an accuracy
point of view but there's actually a
very efficient algorithm just computing
income in comparison you're done and
there's no interest or process neither
so these days when I use these models is
more motivated by computation and less
by performance but this general
principle is one that will come back to
you again it's a table oh right so what
happens to the covariance matrices are
different it turns out that Tara it
still ends up being a little function of
a bunch of quadratic terms in the
religious functions there's not a linear
decision boundary at the one you can end
up with a decision boundary you know
that looks like this right what positive
negative examples separated by some by
some other shape you can you can you
could you can think actually I encourage
you to you know fire up Python numpy and
and play around their parameters and
plot this for yourself
yeah is recommended needs some signal
test to see if is Gaussian um I can tell
you what's done in practice I think in
practice if you have enough data to do a
Cisco testing in conviction you probably
have enough data to just use logistic
regression
i I don't know well no that's not really
fair I don't know if they're very high
dimensional data I think what often
happens more is people just plot the
data and if it looks clearly non
Gaussian then you know that would be
reason to not use G da but what happens
often is that sometimes you just have a
very small training set and it's just a
matter of judgment right like if you
have if you have a you know 50 examples
of healthcare records then you just have
to ask some doctors and ask well do you
think the distribution is rather
relatively Gaussian it use domain
knowledge like that
I think but wait another philosophical
points um I think that the machine
learning world has a little bit
overhyped Big Data right and yes it's
true that way more data is great and I
love data and having more data pretty
much never hurts and usually the more
they do the better so all that is true
and I think we did a good job telling
people that high-level message you know
more data almost always helps but um I
think a lot of the skill in machine
learning these days is getting your
algorithms to work even when you don't
have a million in examples you don't
have a million examples so there are
lots of machine learning applications we
just don't have a million examples you
have a hundred examples and it's then
the skill in designing and learning our
matters much more so if you take
something like image that million images
there are now dozens of teams maybe
hundreds of teams I don't know they can
get great results if you have a million
examples right and so the performance
difference between teams you know there
are now dozens of teams that get great
performance different million examples
for image classification that image them
but if you have only a hundred examples
then the high school teams will actually
do much much much much better than the
loss
all teams whereas the performance gap is
smaller when you have giant data sets I
think so and I think that is these types
of intuitions you know what assumptions
to use genitive or the spirit of that
actually distinguishes the high school
teams and the less experienced teams and
drives a lot of performance differences
when you have small data oh and if
someone goes to you and says oh you only
have a hundred examples you never do
anything then I don't know if is a
competitor saying that then I'll say
great you know don't do it because I can
make it work well I don't know but I
think there are a lot of applications
where you're still designing a machine
learning system really makes a bigger
difference when you're make mixer it
makes the difference from Big Data and
small danger but it's just this is very
clear when you don't know much data
it's the assumptions you call into the
algorithm like is a Gaussian is it
possible that that skill allows you to
drive much bigger their performance then
lower skill team would be able to take
questions to help you go ahead
oh sure so does this
yeah so what's the general statement of
this yes so if x given y equals 1 comes
from an exponential family distribution
xq y equal 0 comes with exponential
family surge in the same expansion
family distribution and if they vary
only by the natural parameter of a
special family distribution then this
would be richest signal yeah I think
this was once a midterm homework problem
to prove this actually yeah all right
actually wanted to take one last
question everyone oh just performance
improvement how even as you increase
number of crosses oh yeah I think so yes
and the generalization of this would be
the softmax regression we should then
talk about it but yes I think a similar
thing holds true for G here for multiple
and yeah so far when I talk about binary
classification whether you have more
than two classes but yes similar similar
things so it's true for GPA was three
classes in softmax oh yes right you saw
soft back through the name cool um and
this this theme that when you have less
data the algorithm needs to rely more on
assumptions yuko then this is a
recurring theme that we'll come back to
it as well this is one of the important
principles of machine learning that when
you have less data your skill at coding
in your knowledge matters much more this
is a theme we'll come back to when we
talk about much more complicated
learning algorithms
so I want a fresh board for this
so you see GTA in the context of
continuous valued features X the last
thing I want to do today is talk about
one more generative learning algorithm
called naive Bayes and I'm gonna use as
most of you example email spam
classification but this this is I guess
is our first foray into natural language
processing right give it a piece of text
like given a piece of email can you
classify this as spam or non-spam or
other examples actually several years
ago eBay use of a problem of someone's
trying to sell something and you write a
text description right here you have a
secondhand you know rumor I'm trying to
sell it on eBay how do you take that
text that someone wrote up a description
and categorize it is an electronic thing
or they trying to sell TV are they
trying to sell clothing but these these
examples there's text classification
problems we have a piece of text and you
want to classify it into one of two
categories for spam or non-spam or one
of maybe thousands of categories and
you're trying to take a proper
description and classify it into one of
the classes and so the first question we
will have is given an email problem give
an email classification problem how do
you represent it as a feature vector and
so in naive Bayes what we're going to do
is take your email take a piece of email
and first map it to a feature vector X
and we'll do so as follows which is
first this starts with a let's start of
an English dictionary and make a list of
all the words in the English dictionary
right it's the first word in the English
dictionary is a second where the English
nation is all wrong
third word is aardwolf
look it up and then you know email spam
la población buy stuff so the visual
would buy right and then and in the last
word in my dictionary is Sigma Y which
is the technological chemistry that
refers to the fermentation process in
brewing so I think it doesn't useful way
to think about it in practice what you
do is not actually a local a dictionary
but look at the top 10,000 words you
know in your training set right there so
maybe you have 10,000 it's easier to
think about it as if it was the
dictionary but you know in practice what
you the other thing that's that you have
too many words but wait the other way to
do it is to look through your own email
corpus and just find the top 10,000
occurring words and use that as a
feature service so oh no right and your
emails because you're getting a bunch of
email about from a so many others about
69 so CSU tonight might appear in your
dictionary of building an email spam
filter for yourself even if it doesn't
appear in the official was it the
dictionary just yet just just just you
wait well we'll get Susan I there's
something all right
and so given an email what we would like
to do is then take this piece of text
and represented this feature vector and
so one way to do this is you can create
a binary feature vector that puts a 1 if
it were it appears in an email and put a
0 if it doesn't right so if you got an
email that asks you to you know buy some
stuff and the word a appears an email or
the one there they're not trying to sell
a Vockrodt will so 0 there by and so on
right so you take a take an email and
turn it into a binary feature vector and
so here the feature vector is 0 1 to the
N because there's an N dimensional
binary feature vector where we're for
the purpose of illustration let's say
and there's 10,000 because you're using
you know take the top 10,000 words that
appear in your email training set as the
dictionary that you will use so so in
other words X I is indicator word I
appears in DINO so is either 0 1
depending on whether or not that word I
from this list appears in your email now
in the naive Bayes algorithm we're going
to build a generative learning algorithm
and so we want a model P of x given Y as
well as P of Y but there are two to the
10,000 possible values of X because X is
a binary vector of this 10,000
dimensional so if we try to mount model
P of X in the straight phone way as a
multinomial distribution over you know
two to the 10,000 possible outcomes then
you need right you need you know two to
the ten thousand parameters right which
is a lot that's the technique you need
two to ten thousand minus one parameters
because that add up to one since a1
tanta but so modeling this without
additional assumptions won't won't work
right because excessive number of
parameters so in the naive Bayes
algorithm I'm going to assume that s
eyes are conditionally independent
given why okay let me just write down
what this means but so P of X 1 up to X
10,000 given Y by the chain rule of
probability this is equal to P of X 1
given Y times P of X 2 given X 1 and Y
times P of X 3 given X 1 X 2 y up to P
of X 10,000 so I haven't made any
assumptions yet this is just a true
statement of fact there's always true by
the chain rule of probability and what
we're going to assume which is what this
assumption is is that this is equal to
this first term no change so this
assumption is called a conditional
independence assumption is also
sometimes called the naive Bayes
assumption but you're assuming that so
honest you know why the chance of seeing
the word odd vaak in your email does not
depend on whether the word a appears in
your email and this is one of those
assumptions it's definitely not a true
assumption and that is just not
mathematically true assumption just that
sometimes your data isn't perfectly
Gaussian but the assumed is Gaussian you
can kind of get away with it so this
assumption is not true in a mathematical
sense but it maybe not so horrible that
you can't get away with it and so decide
if you have any of you are familiar
problems with graphical models we've
taken CS 228 this assumption is
summarized in this picture and if you
haven't you can see s 228 this picture
won't make sense
don't worry about it right that duck
once you know the cost label is the spam
or non-spam whether or not each word
appears what does not appear is
independent okay so this is called
conditional so the mechanics of this
assumption is really just captured by
this equation and you just use this
equation that's all you need to derive
naive Bayes but the intuition is that if
I tell you whether this piece if I tell
you that this piece of email is spam
then whether the word buy appears in it
doesn't affect you believes that well
whether the word mortgage or discount or
whatever spam your words appear so just
to summarize this is the product from I
equals 1 through n P of X agree
alright so the parameters of this model
are I'm gonna write it fine subscript J
given y equals 1 as the probability that
X J equals 1 given y equals 1 J Phi and
just to distinguish all these Phi's from
each other I'm gonna just call this Phi
subscript Y ok so this parameter says if
a spam email if y equals 1 is family why
is it zeros non-spam ever spam email
what's the chance of where J appearing
in the email if it's not spam email
an email and then also what's the cost
prior what's the probability that the
next email you receive in your and so um
to fit the parameters this model you
would similar to gas industry analysis
right out the John joint likelihood so
the joint likelihood of these parameters
is the product you know given these
parameters
right similar to what we had for
Gaussian disappearance and maximum
likelihood estimates if you take this
take logs take the river to set there as
a zero solve for the values that
maximize this you find that the master
likely estimated the parameters are fine
why it's pretty much what you'd expect
it's just a fraction of spam emails and
Phi of J given y equals one is well
alright design an indicator function
notation
so that's the indicator function
notation I'm writing out look through
your training set find all the spam
emails and of all the stamp emails ie
examples of y equals one counter what
fraction of them had where J in it
right so your estimate of a chance of
where J appearing yes there's no chance
of the work by appearing and spam email
is just well of all the spam emails in
your training set what fraction of them
contained the word by what fraction of
them had your XJ equals one let's say
the word by okay and so it turns out
that if you implement this algorithm it
will it will nearly work I guess but
this is naive Bayes for for email spam
classification and I'll mentioned one
reason this and it turns out that what
one thinks to this algorithm which we'll
talk about on Wednesday this is actually
is actually a not too horrible stand
classifier it turns out that to be used
logistic regression for spam
classification YouTube better than this
almost all the time but this is a very
efficient algorithm because estimating
these parameters is discounting and then
computing probabilities is just
multiplying a bunch of numbers so
there's nothing iterative about this see
couldn't fit this model very efficiently
and also keep on updating this model
even as you get new data even it again
you knew you know users hits Marcus spam
or whatever and you've insecure mutate
so you can update this model very
efficiently but it turns out that
actually the biggest problem with this
algorithm is what happens if this is 0
over if if you get zeros in some of
these equations right we'll come back to
that when we talk about the plus moving
on Wednesday
okay all right nuclear questions before
you wrap up okay good so now you love
about generative learning algorithms
we'll come back on Wednesday and learn
about some more fine details how to make
this work because that's it so let's
break you'll see on Wednesday